wir begrüßen den spd-chef bei uns im zdf
morgenmagazin lars klingbeil 5 und
morgen es ist ein großes ein voluminöses
paket umfang circa 65 milliarden euro
und dazu gehört auch das abschöpfen so
genannter zufalls gewinne auf dem
strommarkt ist es die von der spd
geforderte über gewinn steuer in
abgewandelter vor es ist der richtige
mechanismus wir sehen dass es gerade
viele gibt die ohne eigenes zutun
gewinne machen weil der strommarkt
durcheinander ist getrieben auch von der
entwicklung beim gas und wir haben jetzt
als regierung gesagt wir greifende ein
das ist ein ganz wichtiges signal zu
sagen wir greifen in den strommarkt ein
und da wo gewinne durch zufall passieren
da werden wir diese gewinne abschöpfen
und wir geben sie haben die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher zurück
ich hätte vor ein paar tagen nicht
gedacht dass das gelingt dass wir das im
koalitionsausschuss verabreden also das
ist ein wichtiges signal für die
verbraucher wenn verbraucher in diesem
land und auch für die kleinen mittleren
unternehmen ja alle beteiligten
regierungspartner sind da wohl lange
wege gegangen bei den verhandlungen also
vielleicht müssen wir das noch mal kurz
erläutern alle unternehmen auf dem
strommarkt die ohne teures russisches
gas produzieren die müssen mit einer
erlös obergrenze rechnen alles darüber
hinaus sollten abgeschafft werden und
dazu gehören auch wind- solar- und auch
wasserkraftwerke die ja eigentlich für
die energiewende stehen darum jetzt also
die frage wird beziehungsweise kann das
rechtlich bestand haben ist ja ein
enormer markt das ist ja das mag prinzip
was wir gerade haben dazu gehört
übrigens auch das will ich sagen die zu
wird kohle dazu wird auch atomar es sind
die beiden energieform die auch mit aber
auch die über gewinne abgeschöpft die
anderen auch aber die haben alle gerade
einfach über gewinne zufalls gewinne und
wir sagen das kann nicht sein dass die
gerade die tasche voll bekommen mit geld
und die bürgerin und bürger mehr
bezahlen und deswegen müssen wir dieses
prinzip ändern und das tun wir verstehe
aber die frage wird das rechtlich
bestand haben da gehe ich aus also das
wird europäisch die kommission treibt
das voran wir haben das national geprüft
und wir machen das jetzt entweder sehr
schnell europäisch oder sehr schnell
national wir warten jetzt ein paar tage
auf europa und sonst entscheiden wird
dass du das hier in deutschland machen
naturgemäß gibt es kritik von der
opposition vor gut einer stunde war der
unions-fraktionsvize hier und sparen bei
uns monat folgendes gesagt schauen wir
uns das gemeinsame
[Musik]
wenn man das einfach mal durchliest das
aufgeschrieben ist dann ist das ja mehr
ein arbeitsprogramm für die regierung
als wirklich ein sofort wirksames
entlastungsprogramm strompreis bremse
ist gut aber keiner weiß bei welchem
preis keiner weiß wann sie in kraft
tritt nachfolgeregelung 9 euro ticket
wird beschrieben man will was tun ob was
wann wie kommt ist völlig offen also es
gibt in der reihe von wahrheiten von
konkreten die am ende mich eben sagen
lassen die summe die man den raum stellt
die klingt ganz gut aber wenn man genau
hinschaut bleibt wenig übrig
sagt also ihren sparen gute ideen aber
wenig konkretes zu wenig fokussiert
lassen sie das gelten was soll er denn
sagen stellen sie sich vor er setze ich
würde morgen hin und lobt dass wir was
gutes auf den weg gebracht haben das ist
ein paket das hilft gerade an einer ganz
schweren zeit und die nächsten wochen
und monate werden hart da bin ich mir
sicher wir müssen zusammenstehen wir
müssen uns unterhaken und die regierung
hat jetzt viele einzelne dinge auf den
weg gebracht werden jetzt sehr schnell
sehr konkret umgesetzt und die helfen
den bürgerinnen und bürgern die helfen
den mittelstand um durch die nächsten
monate ein wenig durchzukommen wir
federn ab darum geht es und ich hoffe
auf die konstruktivität der region der
der opposition auch in diesen fällen das
abschöpfen dieser sogenannten zufalls
gewinne das finanziert oder soll dann
finanzieren die strompreis bremse und da
ist die frage wieso greift die erst in
ein paar monaten und wieso nicht so vor
sie musste entwickelt werden es geht ja
zum beispiel um die frage aber das ist
doch wenig konkret welche parameter
legen während wir haben einen
koalitionsausschuss der jetzt eine
politische richtung beschlossen hat
jetzt wird herr habeck in seinem
ministerium deshalb zuständig wird daran
arbeiten nach welchen parametern
passiert das geht es um den verbrauch
der letzten zwei drei jahre geht es um
haushaltsgrößen aber es muss jetzt
schnell passieren das ist klar
verabredet worden im koalitionsausschuss
wir haben keine zeit zu verlieren das
muss jetzt schnell umgesetzt werden
diese strompreis bremse kommt aber noch
mal dass wir in den strommarkt
eingreifen das übrigens auch geöffnet
haben beim thema gas das wir dort
überlegen werden ob wir eingreifen das
ist ein signal da hätte ich vor zwei
wochen nicht gedacht dass das alle
koalitionspartner mitmachen und das
halte ich für ein riesenerfolg und auch
für ein wichtiges signal an die
gewerkschaften an die industrie an den
mittelstand dass wir sagen wir werden
nicht akzeptieren dass die merck jeder
völlig aus dem ruder laufen obwohl es
auch von dort kritik gibt nochmal so
strompreis bremse davon profitieren auch
gutverdiener ist das gerecht das ist
eine schnelle entscheidung die jetzt da
sein muss und das betrifft dann alle die
gerade hohe strompreise haben ich mache
jetzt kein hehl daraus dass ich mir
jetzt sozialdemokrat immer vorstellen
könnte dass man noch wo grenzen einzieht
aber dann dauert es länger das ganze
umzusetzen und deswegen war es richtig
jetzt zu sagen wir brauchen etwas was
schnell funktioniert wir wollen schnell
in die märkte eingreifen und dafür ist
das richtig schnell ist ein gutes
stichwort für meine letzte frage sie
betrifft die nachfolgeregelung für das 9
euro ticket da soll es etwas geben aber
keiner weiß wann ist das geben wird weil
dazu ihr die länder von nöten sind also
wie schnell muss man jetzt mit einer
einigung rechnen und volker wissing hat
ja angekündigt dass bis zum jahresende
die nachfolgeregelung stehen soll und
auf das wort verlasse ich mich sagt lars
klingbeil der spd-chef zum dritten
entlastungspaket vielen dank für den
besuch heute bei uns sehr gerne